no
god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just tuned in
some serious couples counseling
welcome back everyone this is gonna be
my venom let there be carnage trailer
video there's a whole bunch of new
footage in easter eggs so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there are even more
spider-man easter eggs we'll talk about
that too i know everybody's still
wondering where the spider-man no way
home trailer is more like spider-man no
way we're getting that trailer but the
whole idea here is that we're just
getting a way better look at the carnage
symbiote and they're hyping up way more
their relationship like he says to me
eddie your family as in literally family
because carnage is the spawn of the
venom symbiote they also pretty much
explain how he gets the carnage symbiote
is a slight twist on the comic book
origin for carnage venom still seems
like he spawns it just seems like from
the events of the trailer he basically
bites eddie and ingests some of his
blood but his blood has been mixed with
the venom symbiote and so it's eddie's
blood with the venom symbiote mixing
with cletus cassidy's blood that then
causes it to spawn into the carnage
symbiote it feels like they've also
polished a lot of the special effects
since they released that last big
trailer but starting at the beginning of
the trailer going through shot by shot
they start with him on the ducati out in
the countryside his motorcycle helmet is
red and black carnage theme sort of
foreshadowing the big twist that's
coming up the way that andy circus the
director explained their relationship
when the movie picks up is that as you
can see in the trailer the venom
symbiote is frustrated he's saying i'm a
predator we should be out there eating
bad guys but eddie brock doesn't want to
have any of that he's like no no you
can't eat people even though they made
the bargain at the end of the first
movie you can only eat bad people it's
almost as if he's pulling back on that
in the venom symbiote just getting
really really frustrated when he's
saving this person from what seems like
a mugger it's hard to tell when this is
happening it could be a little bit
earlier in the film so it's meant to
show you that he still is eating a
couple bad people here and there but not
nearly as many as the venom symbiote
probably wants to i don't know why this
tire says snooki on it some sort of
weird jersey shore reference we go to
the ravencroft institute obviously a big
place from the spider-man comics it's
also the same place during the amazing
spider-man andrew garfield films where
they ended that film teasing the big
sinister six reveal where harry osborne
in that franchise was creating a new
version of the sinister six back at
oscorp there's a rumor that we might see
a version of oscorp sometime in the next
couple of big spider-man spin-off movies
so we'll see but the whole idea is that
ravencroft is where cletus cassidy's
girlfriend so to speak shriek is being
held but you can clearly see that she's
either a mutant or a metahuman we'll see
how they explain that during the movie i
haven't heard them talk too much about
that she does have special powers very
clearly later in the trailer you also
see her use her abilities to basically
smash the whole front of the car off in
the windshield shariq was a big part of
the maximum carnage storylines so you
can see they're adapting some of maximum
carnage for this first story of venom
versus carnage i was always hoping they
were going to do a version of that in
the movies at some point but because it
wasn't totally clear how they're going
to involve the spider-man character even
though there's a lot of spider-man
easter eggs now it's hard to tell how
much maximum carnage they're going to be
doing because maximum carnage was not
carnage's origin story you kind of built
up to that and the whole idea was that
during that storyline spider-man and
venom teamed up to take down carnage so
this sort of explains how things go so
crazy once cletus cassidy ingests his
blood and gets a taste of the venom
symbiote and why the venom symbiote
reacts the way it does when it bonds
with cletus cassidy is like the purest
expression of what it's asking for here
just be completely free free from all
the logic that's tying eddie down the
fact that he wants to be a normal person
and exist in the world with other people
then later in the trailer you see them
have a sort of renaissance as carnage
has manifested like okay now you can eat
anybody you want because things have
gone so crazy we need to take out all
these bad guys the whole thing with the
cletus cassidy plot though like it seems
like he knows more about what's going on
with eddie and the symbiote than he lets
on i think that he's just a little
obsessed with eddie brock as this
reporter and as a serial killer he just
craves that attention from the media and
i think the idea was that earlier eddie
brock had been writing all these
articles about him that helped him get
put in prison so their relationship goes
back way before the events of the first
film but the story that he's talking
about giving eddie i want to give you my
story he wants to tell eddie about all
these other bodies that the police never
found that he hid all over the place as
you can see them digging up what seems
like some of those bodies here on this
beach you notice the notes the cletus
cassidy the drawings he's been sending
to eddie it says to the strife has been
given between the suffering there's a
little heart on the tree then there's a
drawing of the church that it seems like
they're fighting at later in the movie
he also knows that certain frequencies
sonic weapons are deadly against the
venom symbiotes so they might use a
similar twist as the venom origin story
with the church bells to try and stop
cletus cassidy or at least hamstring him
during this movie eddie brock seems like
he's writing this article for the daily
bugle so obviously big spider-man
reference but it's the daily bugle logo
from the toby maguire spider-man movies
we know the morbius movie is a direct
spin-off of the venom movies and it's
going to be happening right after this
movie early next year during that
trailer we saw a very notable toby
mcguire spider-man costume i've already
explained how the director andy circus
said that during the events of this
movie cletus cassidy eddie brock
detective mulligan the toxin character
from the comics who seems like he's
working with eddie brock as part of this
big article that he's riding on cletus
cassidy have no idea are not aware of
the existence of a spider-man that
doesn't mean that spider-man doesn't
exist on this earth but we just had the
loki series we just had that big twist
with kang in the true version of the
multiverse being unleashed so i will
address that because there is an easter
egg that seems like it's sort of hinting
at that towards the end of the trailer
i've already done a couple videos about
how the sony executives the president of
sony pictures have explained how they do
have a plan for connecting all this and
it'll basically be laid bare like
they'll explain everything during
spider-man no way home which based on
some of the stuff we've learned about
the movie seems like it contains a lot
of spider-verse multiverse elements that
are based on what happened at the end of
the loki series cletus cassidy says
what's mine is yours and what's yours is
mine as he literally bites him and
basically takes essentially takes the
carnage symbiote for himself although
that's not exactly the way it goes down
he takes his blood which is laced with
the venom symbiote then the venom
symbiote spawns like it does in the
comics and that creates the carnage
symbiote the change that they made from
the comic book origin story for carnage
is that they were actually cell mates
the venom symbiote came and busted eddie
brock out but while it was rescuing
eddie it spawned left behind a piece of
itself that piece bonded with cletus
cassidy in that form the carnage
symbiote so here eddie's kind of leaving
a piece of that symbiote behind but not
because it's spawned it's because cletus
cassidy literally bit him and ingested
his blood the other interesting thing
here you'll note is that he's wearing
that white prison jumpsuit the same
white prison jumpsuit that michael
keaton's version of the vulture is
wearing during the morbius trailer so
i'm wondering if the prison where
they're getting ready to execute cletus
cassidy here later in the movie because
the color of prison jumpsuit is
different is the same place where
vulture scorpion and then morbius are
going to show up during the morbius
movie like i don't think it's a
coincidence that he's in a white prison
jumpsuit here when they're getting ready
to execute him on death row but it seems
like he doesn't have any idea what's
going on with a carnage symbiote until a
manifest bursts out of him literally
while they're in the middle of executing
him i like the way they foreshadow this
too because right before it happens you
see eddie flip his visor down and it's a
red helmet he has red stripes going down
the back just foreshadowing the carnage
twist it kind of seems like by this
point of the movie they actually have
gone to new york city so it seems like
that's the connection to spider-man
homecoming the vulture and those
sinister six characters then there's
this huge battle that seems like they
have in this church getting very
biblical also a lot of references back
to the venom origin story with
spider-man and the church bells if
you're not a big comic book reader there
was also this whole thing with the cult
of carnage during the marvel comics too
and we get our full carnage reveal and
because of the way they color correct
this you get a slightly better look at
what he actually looks like in broad
daylight he's not quite as bright red as
he is in the comics but i think they
just want to have a little more parody
with the venom symbiote everybody use
your family guy memes because he totally
says the name of the movie inside the
trailer all i want in this life is
carnage oh he said the thing the thing
with carnage's powers that are a little
bit different from venom is he's much
quicker to manifest weapons using the
symbiote whereas the venom symbiote
doesn't do that quite as much there's a
bunch more special effects of him
breaking out of prison you see a little
bit better how the symbiote works like
they literally fire a giant hole through
his chest that the symbiote just closes
up instantly they just want to hype up
how op and almost unkillable carnage is
going to be the idea that eddie brock
could be way more powerful with the
venom symbiote than he's letting himself
be because he's holding back so hard
this is cletus cassidy after he's become
carnage breaking his girlfriend shriek
out of ravencroft then whatever happens
during the film maybe because the
article that eddie writes about him or
something in that article he swears
revenge on him i also think originally
eddie was responsible for getting him
put in prison in the first place like
way back before the events of the first
film so that's the connection back to
anne wang's character who is back for
the sequel they did tease that they
would be doing more lady venom stuff
during this like she would also wear the
symbiote again at some point during the
film but we don't get a ton from her in
this trailer and it seems that she's
about to get married to her doctor
boyfriend from the first film they play
that mostly for comedy in the venom
symbiote not being able to deal with
that that should be us getting married
to her i love this scene here too when
the venom symbiote sees the karna
symbiote for the first time and reacts
to it oh that's a red one it just
seems like it doesn't immediately
understand the relationship between it
and carnage like eventually it will
understand oh that came from me that's
sort of like my spawn that's like my
child essentially the relationship
between the different symbiotes is kind
of funny like carnage eventually spawns
the toxin symbiote and that bonds with
detective mulligan who's a character
during this so maybe they'll tease that
for future sequels they'll eventually do
the toxin symbiote but the carnage
symbiote hates the toxin symbiote like
it hates its own spawn and wants to kill
it when cletus cassidy says eddie you
feel like home to me that's just another
reference to the relationship between
the venom symbiote and the carnage
symbiote the scene of cletus cassidy
kicking this bodega owner it's hard to
tell where this is happening if it's in
new york city if it's back in san
francisco there's a couple more scenes
of him breaking out a prison of him
breaking shriek out of ravencroft we get
a bunch more scenes of the carnage
symbiote just manifesting you see it
just looking around the way it's going
to visualize during the film is way
wilder way more fluid looking than the
venom symbiote and during a couple
scenes in the trailer they do show you
license plates and usually when they
show you a license plate it is a comic
book reference to something but i can't
really detect any big comic book easter
eggs for eddie's license plate on his
bike but at the end of the trailer on
their car here on the license plate it
reads 65 1965 was actually a big year
for marvel comics that's the same year
that king the conqueror debuted or he
debuted as king the conqueror but the
whole idea is that king the conqueror is
going to be the new big main overarching
villain of the mcu in marvel phase 4
like the new thanos level villain that
feels like it's a subtle wink at what
happened at the end of the loki series
with the multiverse kang war that
they're using for the plot of spider-man
no way home the big multiverse plot
spider-verse plot and they'll be using
that same logic to explain how
spider-man can eventually cross over
with the venom movies and how everything
is connected between the sony marvel
movies the venom movies in the mcu
marvel movies with tom hall and
spider-man like everything is suddenly
canon now because of what loki and
sylvie did at the loki finale thank you
very much sylvie but i'm not expecting a
ton of big references to that during the
events of venom let there be carnage i
think the way the sony executive
explained it is mostly spider-man no way
home where they're going to be
explaining how that's all going to work
so that might be why they're holding off
so much on the trailer for that just
because they're not quite ready to
explain how that's going to work i also
did a video a little while ago where
kevin feige was talking about putting
venom inside the mcu but because of what
they did with the loki series it sounds
like now kevin feige is much more open
to introducing venom into the mcu proper
at some point if you spotted any big
easter eggs that i didn't talk about
during the trailer just write them below
in the comments and i will do more venom
videos as we get more footage from the
movie next week the marvel what if
episodes are starting i will be doing
full episode videos for all those so
make sure you have alerts enabled for
that it'll also be trading heavily on
the multiverse themes of what happened
at the end of the loki series will you
wait for everything click here for my
brand new marvel shanxi trailer video in
easter eggs learn how it's connected to
the iron man movies and click here for
my new loki video about the connection
between iron man and kane the conqueror
in the mcu thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and i'll see
you guys in the next video
you